this week on quadriga Germany goes to
war at what price after last month's
terror attacks on Paris Chancellor
Angela Merkel promised France Germany's
backing now it's time to turn words into
deeds Germany is set to commit tornado
reconnaissance jets to an anti is
Alliance and the Bundys veil will be
helping to ease the burden on the French
military in Mali but in the German
parliament the bundestag there's
opposition critics say there's no exit
strategy can is be eradicated by
military might or is Germany being
sucked into another ill-advised military
adventure coming to you from Berlin
quant Riga the international debate your
host this week Melinda crane hello and
welcome to quad Riga the military
mission looks set to be approved but
does Germany have a clear strategy
that's what we want to talk about today
with three people who are following the
debate very closely it's a pleasure to
welcome Oh Rico groove oh she's a
political analyst and founder and
director of the European democracy lab
she says one mustn't confuse fighting
terror with war what France hopes to
achieve with its military alliance is
questionable equally questionable
whether there's a clear strategy and
what it means for French German
relations Ellen Posner welcome back to
the program once again he's a seasoned
political journalist for the Berlin
newspaper developed and he says Germany
has no choice but to back France the
alternative would be the collapse of the
European Union
and finally freed Rouge tailin is with
us today he worked for over 30 years for
the booze net business newspaper via
chavala as bureau chief both in bonn and
in berlin today he runs his own
consulting company he says we have
entered into this military mission very
hastily if you decide to intervene ilum
in a military conflict you should always
have an exit strategy so welcome to all
of you Ellen Posner you say Germany has
no choice but is the German contribution
to the air strikes against is really
going to make any difference American
warplanes have already been doing
reconnaissance drones are also in action
what do the reconnaissance tornados of
the Germans really add they don't add up
to much nor does the the frigate which
is patrolling in the ethernet Iranian
don't forget we had an operation there
in these and my dreams to stop hizbollah
getting weapons and Hizballah now has
more rockets than ever before so the the
success of this is moot to say the least
this is a political gesture the French
wanted European solidarity and it was up
to Germany to step forward and give it
them the British obviously are doing
much more than first strikes against
Syria already this morning but within
its limits Germany is proving itself to
be a good Ally that's basically the
measure of it ok kaguro how legitimate
is that objective one member of the
German governing coalition the
parliamentary leader for the Christian
social Union said this week this isn't a
war mission it's a sign of solidarity
with France is that a real strategy well
and then a strategy to do what I mean if
it's a strategy to fight the is with
military means we can question this I
would make the argument I would like to
make the argument that the real danger
what we are really overlooking these
days is the phone national in France so
if this is the real danger and if the
question is how Germany can be solid
Arian with its most important partner
country then the question is whether the
current strategy which is military in
treatment is fueling or not fueling the
phone as you're not my argument here is
that what we do will fuel marine lepen
for a couple of reasons one is we do a
collision building military coalition
with Putin who is financing marine lepen
second if we go with Assad Assad is
responsible for bombing Syria is
responsible for the refugees so is
responsible for the hatred against the
refugees in our country Germany and in
France and we perhaps do this alliance
building also with Saudi Arabia who is
financing the country is financing the
bone use of France where the
radicalization is growing so we do three
wrong things to fight the real problem
of France which is the phone as unit
Swedish alien a letter from the german
foreign and defense ministry's said that
the deployment is aimed at preventing
terrorist acts by is in other words
directly addressing the aftermath of the
attacks in Paris but do you think this
military mission will really do that or
might it actually make terrorist attacks
more likely I think it's a very
courageous sentence to say that is going
preventing terrorist attacks iya well my
my idea about all things we are getting
into a war and we don't know where it
ends for those who were not so familiar
with military strategy you sent reckon
and you need fighting pilots around to
protect them against any attack from the
other side dan you need helicopter crews
to get if planes shot down you must get
the crews out at the beginning and
everyone who knows the area and says
there is no way to get rid of a is
without true normal troops normal troops
well I don't know the sort of the
gathering units in this country know
what that means if the first buddies
come here and then or more but it's
being sent there in a war where everyone
is everyone everyone else's enemy I'm in
there shooting each other nobody knows
that and we don't have that is the worst
don't have an exit strategy we don't
know how what sort of aim we want do we
want a real
nized near East was a new pic on line
like after nineteen eighteen nineteen 19
verse I and the following conferences
splitting up the nearest we have no idea
do the Kurds get their homeland with
parts of Turkey well that is what the
president that were by opening doesn't
want at all so what do we want in other
words do I understand all three of you
to be in consensus on the fact that this
military admission is not going to
achieve any real goals in terms of
defeating is no no I mean I'm just
saying that the German part of this
mission is relatively subdued relatively
minor I think stepping up the military
attacks as Britain is doing France has
done the United States is doing and we
must get the Saudis and the Gulf states
and add one to really cooperate on this
and not go along with Assad and and his
Russian backers if we can do that if we
can see the point is that wherever the
Caliphate comes is they write on the
walls we are here and we are getting
bigger and we have to disprove that
because that's propagate that their main
propaganda and if we can do that and
then we're one step towards where you
want to go to it's just a small step but
it's a necessary step or like a good oh
you say we need to start at home I take
the point do we not need to do anything
abroad against is no I have been saying
this i mean i'm also not against a
military mission at all price but if we
do that we should be serious i mean
there's a huge divide the baked about
ground troops and if we can build i mean
if the aim of holanda is to set a clear
european example that united we stand
that we want to build a European defense
alliance and we could do this was the US
which is our main Western partners then
and then we pretend to be the super sort
of west with whatever military means
then we should be able to go against
30,000 people of troops which is the is
but then you should be serious just this
sort of diffusive strategy that we fly
some drones which are you know will also
kill people there and we'll probably go
into a violence of
spiral of violence because the more we
fly unperson 'old roans over syria and
then we get the bombs in Europe I think
it's not a clear strategy let alone that
we don't have a strategy with whom we go
because as I said what we do not do is
that we link everything that is
happening there back to what is
happening here what has happened that is
as much important what is happening here
is the complete erosion of the party
systems in Europe we have the polls and
say I want to come back to the question
of who are bedfellows MI tía in this
military mission but one more word on
the question of strategy flesh tailin
the germany's foreign minister
frank-walter Steinmeier insisted during
a very heated parliamentary debate this
week that the military mission is very
firmly embedded in a larger overall
political strategy to find a solution
for Syria and he pointed of course to
the multi-party meetings in Vienna that
haven't have been going on are they not
at least a step in the right direction
and significantly more than anything
we've seen in the last few years agreed
that's okay if they really get from okay
the bet is a very difficult task to get
the yard once the ious people and saudi
arabian everyone in there why don't we
start with something else all the money
which is going to fly in there it
doesn't come from oil being cut out of
in in Syria and unsold to the charts
rubbish what is important is there the
cut of this Saudi Arabian royal family
and the other royal or whatever families
around the Gulf states supporting with
hundreds of millions these troops
otherwise the is would not be operable
well if a very simple if you have ten
thousand dollars we want to send them
around the world and to someone who
doesn't you don't want international
authorities not only NSA everyone even
the banks can fight there is no way you
can transform money without transfer
money without having be seen so how does
the money get there why don't the
americas not use their influence to stop
it dry it out certainly support from the
Gulf states in Saudi Arabia is one
source but the new york times reported
this week that actually the main
part of the income that is is receiving
is from so-called taxes that it imposes
within its territory which makes
military experts say rolling is back on
the ground is crucial the question is
will this military mission accomplished
that well it can because if you degrade
them them instance we're hitting their
oil transporters very hard now it's a
very good thing totally agree we have to
hit the money flow totally and we have
fighters they are fighters in Iraq there
are firefighters Kurdish fighters are
smart um who can who can fight is there
are fighters within Syria confide is so
yes we can defeat is and then we have a
foothold on the ground when it comes to
the negotiations on the basis of the
Vienna agreement so we need to be there
we need to have a presence beyond that
of Assad and and the Russians because
that's an analyst that's my key point we
should do military engagement but not
with the wrong partners because a lot of
partners influence our situation here in
a politically so devastating way that we
have populace problems here which are
arousing our capacity to do that war
that's the connection so let's take a
closer look at those partners critics of
the military missions say that it makes
Germany part of a rather motley crue
definitely the interests and the goals
of the various parties waging war in
Syria are diverse let's take a look in
the war against is the aims of some of
Germany's partners are dubious like
turkish President wretched tie-up
Erewhon
he's more an enemy of the Kurds than
Islamic state that's why Turkish forces
are going after Kurdish positions in
Syria and Iraq as much as possible and
Vladimir Putin is currently being
courted by France in particular along
with is militants Russian warplanes are
hitting moderate rebel and Turkmen
strong points along Syria's border with
Turkey he views almost every participant
in the Syria conflict as a terrorist
except dictator Bashar al-assad who's
terrorizing his own people with barrel
bombs but faced with is terror some
Western politicians are beginning to
view Assad and his army as the lesser of
two evils and even if he receives no
direct cooperation he'll profit from the
fact that his enemies are all embroiled
in other fights flourished alien the
French Foreign Minister Laurent Fabius
speculated last week that it might be
possible to work with some of Assad's
troops to fight against is and
interestingly enough German Defense
Minister Ursula von der Leyen made a
similar statement earlier this week
before retracting it some days later are
we seeing the first moves toward
rehabilitating mr. Assad it looks like
it apart from the fact that i don't
think the john minister of defense is so
much in the topic he acquired the job I
don't know whether she knows enough
about strategy and the rest but you must
have generals telling you the things I
think it's a dangerous a date because
yet the moment we unite ourselves with
Assad you'd automatically have new
enemies the whole putting comes out it's
like putting your hand into a Viper's
nest everyone at the end this come even
you want to protect one it's going to
bite you there's a very good example to
that I've supposed every one of you and
most of our viewers have read rigid
Kipling there is a wonderful book about
one came through to Peshawar that was
the one bicha soldier from an innovation
into Afghanistan who came out of it we
don't want this to happen in Saudi
Arabia I don't think that troop that
will go out at that getting into
conflict without having a clear strategy
to get out
that we could read from clouds of its to
anyone else right fighting about
military strategy only kaguro you were
making this point earlier saying
cooperating with some of these partners
might approve quite counterproductive in
the long run but many people would say
it's just a necessary dose of layout
politique we have to work with what we
have to defeat this terrible group Isis
doing the wrong thing is never good and
it always fights back and it will fight
back and it fights back where you don't
expect it that's all I'm saying the
thing is that we don't link back to what
is happening here and what is happening
here is the complete erosion of
political party systems in many European
countries in Poland annoyin in France
and you know we have we have a true
populist threat the populace red come
and it's is devastating for for
democracy in in Europe this red comes
from refugees the refugees come from
Assad bombing Syria so why should we
cooperate with Assad why should we
cooperated with Putin who's first
annexing the crim but second financing
reform national and I said it why should
we I Saudi Arabia is so promoting and
fueling the radicalization of the bone
use where the people who were doing
these bombings in Paris were growing so
I think we just need to couple back to
to what what is happening in the in the
ground to what is happening here and
what we are seeing is that we may lose
the capacities for a devastating
momentum in our countries to go to war
and to be capable to act I mean there is
a connection but if I can just follow up
so you say a military mission might be
necessary whom should we work with them
well we have we have if we are the West
and if we are strong and if we have
convictions and if we have a goal and if
you have a strategy then we map this out
we collect our means we do a proper
legal basis and then we go I mean that
would be a strategy in the sense that
flat Lydian just said it this is what
Clausewitz and all the other big people
would they would have been doing is get
your target clear get the operations and
then do it but you know this muddling
through and we now must go into bed with
the wrong people because then we can
think and then also we do not know what
is our what do we want to see do
want to see a Kurdish State is this our
goal do we know that with this we go
knocking against everyone's wishes to
but elder one we need him now for the
refugees I mean it just does not make
sense and the clear we are I think the
clear we could work on the street on a
strategy basically you're right i mean
in an ideal world that's what we're
doing an ideal world would go in with
with with troops the flags flying we
occupy territory occupied button at now
by is and then we'd negotiate with the
rest from a position of strength that
would be 19th century gunboat diplomacy
and I'm all for it I just don't think
it's gonna happen now so then we do the
second thing meath and I and since we're
talking about the for National and
Melinda pen and the erosion of the party
system in Europe you're totally right we
must not work together were people who
want to destroy Europe which is mr.
Putin and his ally mr. Assad we must not
do that under no circumstances but at
the same time we must be seen to be
strong against the people who have
attacked us in Paris there's no other
way mr. alarmed can defeat mrs. the pen
unless they seem to be strong so we do
this and yes what's gonna happen it's
gonna be mission creep we're gonna have
planes shot down we're gonna have to go
in there with and then we're gonna find
us as the troops in there and then we're
gonna have a situation like in Bosnia
and so on and so on but finally and
Bosnia we got it right took some time
but we got it right that's what I'm
hoping for i right yes I could follow
you but Bonilla is a very limited area
very limited with not sup met such a lot
of players here we have as you said
Assad the princes from Saudi Arabia by
the way in the background we have Tehran
with lot of interest in acts upon the
ground yeah this is a sort of strategy
power game in in an area and the weakest
front of them all is here not for the
reason that I put in by za parties that
I don't share that much but for the
support this government we're going to
have if the bodies come up and they will
shown here then the last 50 years of
pacifism which is in this country after
250 of being belligerent now the Germans
so teacher world how peace has to look
like
governments here will lose support in
the country I'd like to take a closer
look at what has often been called that
German culture of restraint since last
year as all of you know members of the
governing coalition here in Germany have
been pushing for Germany to take greater
responsibility on the world stage saying
that inaction is often more problematic
than action what that means for defense
strategy however remains a hotly
contested topic in this country that
indeed for years has cultivated a
culture of military restraint two world
wars turned most Germans into confirmed
pacifists with the help of an American
re-education program after the third guy
fell in 1945 post-war attitudes were
shaped by one overwhelming imperative
and political consensus Germany must
never again be allowed to instigate a
war even the founding of a new military
force the Bundys fair was highly
controversial a peace movement took root
across all sectors of society protesters
demonstrated against any move that
hinted at further remilitarization like
the stationing of NATO missiles on
German soil
the majority of Germans were also
against the bun despairs first military
missions abroad in the Balkans and later
Afghanistan but polls now show that
forty-five percent of Germans favor
committing bondhus fair forces to the
fight against is just 39 percent are
against despite fears the commitment
could provoke terrorist attacks
are the pacifist Germans turning back
into proponents of war
Balika go even years after sending
forces to Afghanistan the German
government avoided the word war because
it didn't want to alienate public
opinion what accounts for the difference
in public opinion now we heard there
forty-five percent of Germans saying
they would support a military mission
against is why the difference well I
mean we have this discussion off of 20
years we have been struggling with the
first sort of a wax Bosnia war and so
but this country is in a way getting
adult if I may say it that way because
we unifying 20 years ago we are also
called for responsibility there was a
huge discussion about German leadership
in Europe and that discussion basically
is that sentiment that Germany cannot be
that little island like Switzerland and
not being engaged in the world I think
it becomes pretty clear to all Germans
now with the refugees on the front door
that we cannot cut from the world that
we are in the danger of the world we
need to fix the problem or to not fix
but be cool responsible for for a while
and i think this triples now into the
german mindset and that's probably part
of the explanation that we are more able
to lead these discussions Alan Posner
the question is how robust that public
support is our title asks the question
we posed as the question what price the
public might be willing to pay let's say
a terrorist attack were to occur on
German territory do you think that would
tip public sentiment against a military
involvement no I doubt it i think
probably would tip public opinion in
favor of hitting back of the people who
did it which is why i think i asked
won't do that unless they really want to
have us in there but no I think you know
when when body bags come home when the
pilot is grilled alive like in like the
job portrait any of the eyelid is bias
it's a question will we then want to get
the people the way the Jordanians want
to or will we then say we've had enough
it's it's just too early to say but i
would think that we're finally as
Rebecca said we realized we we we've
stayed out of this conflict since it
began in 2011 look what it's brought us
importers a million refugees so maybe we
try the other the other tack yep did not
only 911 brought
the refugees here it is this is one of
the well thats nicest sponsored or
whatever country was such a lot of
riches so anyone else is reopened
borders you could do come here even if
there is no war at home look at Libya
what did a good idea that we didn't
participate on getting Qaddafi down I
know a lot of leaders of today's that
thanks heaven if we still had him there
to keep the door from Libya closed this
is cynical yeah sure it's any color but
then if if you did you find it yeah if I
can just come back to our title because
we would like to see if we can answer
that question what price might be the
one that the German public would then
say this price is too high military
experts for example are saying that this
mission could last as long as 10 years
if it's really about routing is is that
something the German public you think
would be willing to be in for the long
haul if it's only six or seven or ten
whatever fighters or reckons the mission
there and not many people dying so they
would see it's like new and mission but
as anyone set without ground troops
there is no chance to pacify the
conflict there will be demand that
Germany has been asked here as a
European Western ally has to show its
reality to the air to the Alliance and
send troops there too and that is a
moment when in German public political
parties lose the support a serious
possibility do you think orly kaguro
that Germany would be asked to send
ground troops to fight against is in
areas Iraq and Syria I wouldn't exclude
that the question will come and that
this country will to discuss which
answers we give in the future yeah and
is it a price the Germans would now I'm
not reasoning in prices I think it's a
wrong tack I mean if the discourse is
about defending our values all values
have a price yeah
and the values is not only defending
security this is the wrong discourse but
what we do is we defend our security but
if we want to different values it will
have a price thank you very much thanks
to all of you for being on the show and
thanks to you out there for tuning in
see you soon
you